Senate committee now hear from Jacob
Lawson I'm at ISS chief coordinator may
the record reflect that he was nearly
one hour late yeah sorry about that
I literally had to fly in from outer
space thanks sister mo satellite natural
disasters have become a thing of the
past
[Music]
we can control our weather mr. president
one of our thermosphere it's satellites
malfunctioned over Afghanistan so your
proposal is what you shut down all
satellite I don't need to remind all of
you how many people dies in catastrophic
climate condition which was no further
resinous are you going back up safe
coming back I promise
have a safe trip sir just don't touch
anything
this is the Jake loss three James Lawson
you were much older than I would have
passed
I mean good by getting tired my access
has been blocked
so Tyler has a dot-com that happen not
all the brothers no folks
it was intentional
this potential for catastrophic weather
events on a global scale
a Geo store we have to shut the system
down
[Music]
has the kill coats is the president and
in your help you're soliciting Secret
Service agents seriously we're
kidnapping the president and a
self-driving cat
[Music]
jeddak if you can't stop it no.13
[Music]
[Music]
you realize you're committing freeze oh
yeah kidnap appraiser and I just own
state secrets yeah anything I'm
forgetting honey honey
sergeant
[Music]
you